I want to go to the congressman now
congressman Cuellar I just want to say
first of all thank you for joining us
because not a lot of Democrats decide to
come on Fox and I really appreciate your
coming on to share your perspective on
this issue really do appreciate it and
Congressman Rokita obviously in
indianapolis you guys have been dealing
with the aftermath of a very popular NFL
star who was killed in a DUI by an
illegal immigrant who since been
deported but let's start with you
congressman Cuellar you hear the anguish
of Pam whose nephew is a phenomenal
human being and and gunned down killed a
few years ago by an illegal immigrant
just sentenced a few days ago what do
you say what do you say after hearing
that anguish and her voice well first of
all I mean I can understand what she's
going through
I got three brothers or peace officers
in fact one of them was a undercover
narcotics officer and then became a
lieutenant in charge of narcotics and he
also right now he's a border sheriff so
I know what it is to have brothers that
are peace officers and not knowing what
could happen from one day to the other
so I understand what it is to have three
family members that are peace officers
and again to me doesn't matter of that
person who killed a peace officer it's
documented or undocumented or somebody
that's here you know whoever goes after
a peace officer we need to make sure
that we throw the book at that
individual well yeah but obviously it
makes it worse does it not and
congressman Rokita we'll get to you on
this I want to have you both on radio
tomorrow as well he obviously shouldn't
been in the country so they would still
be alive most most likely be alive
that's what makes it worse and I know
Congress is working on this bill and the
push for legalization and some more
enforcement provisions changes to the
immigration but I got to tell you I
think people have fed up with his crime
and this has got to stop this is this is
this is madness Laura if I can jump in I
like to say that this was completely
preventable had we had a wall had we had
a wall system had we believed in
enforcing a federal immigration law
what happened to the Colts player and my
constituent Jeff Jeff Merman row last
week wouldn't have happened so these
things are completely preventable but we
have for the first time this go bat goes
back to miss Owens comments for the
first time Laura in American history we
have a political party the demo the
modern Democratic Party who is putting
the interest of illegal aliens of
lawbreakers ahead of law-abiding
citizens Americans it hasn't really
happened before until now and you're
exactly right
Nancy Pelosi I watched her stood on the
House floor for eight hours for illegal
immigrants but wouldn't do it for mrs.
Owens family that's ridiculous
congressman Cuellar my thought here and
maybe it maybe you disagree is that the
Democrats for all their talk about
caring about what happens to the
dreamers they have it in the hand 1.8
million will get amnesty I actually
don't even agree with it but they'll get
it if they go along with this deal but
it seems like they don't want the deal
am I miss reading this well I can't
speak for anybody but I'll speak for
myself first of all the last time we had
amnesty was under a president a
Republican president named Ronald Reagan
working with the Democrat Congress that
was amnesty now what what point are we
going to get over here are we gonna do
legalization are we're gonna do
something else I don't know that's
something that we have to work out but
you gotta understand that you know
whatever we do changes affecting the the
dreamers legalization people for myself
like myself that live on the border we
don't just come in and come to the
border spend a few hours and we think we
know this because if you look at the
crime rate here at the border use in the
FBI statistics the crime rate here let's
say Loretta my hometown or just a crime
rate along the border is lower than the
crime rate the national crime rate in
fact the most dangerous thing about me
being hired the border is what let me
finish the most dangerous thing that I
have here at the border is when I leave
to go work in Washington DC I'm not
talking about the politics but the crime
rate is much higher in Washington
don't even Disney lore but all I can say
all I can say is guys we're gonna have
you back on radio I know this was short
because Pam we had to hear her story but
the idea that we should have more border
crossings because it's so safe in Laredo
I just don't think you're gonna win a
lot of support on that argument
congressman but I get what you're saying
we will it's ridiculous yeah congressman
Rick I appreciate it